I'm gonna play a clip for you here of a
trump supporter talking about
homelessness now homelessness is a very
important issue homelessness is a moral
failing of the United States there's no
reason we have to have homelessness in
the United States there's also no reason
we have to have hunger but we lack a
political will and sort of resolution to
decide we're not going to do it anymore
but this is interesting here is a trump
supporter
complaining about homelessness she says
something very interesting she says she
doesn't see Hispanics out on the street
she sees blacks and whites what does she
mean by this what's the truth of it and
what the hell is going on here let's
listen it has been some of the negative
things since the Biden
you turn your head and you pause for
dramatic effect but me too to be honest
with you yeah we've seen so many
homeless in my life ever never in my
life have I ever seen so many homeless
and it's like okay we're gonna take
we're gonna have open borders I never
see any of the Hispanics on the street
what I see is African-American and
Caucasian American
what is she trying to make in terms of a
point here
I I don't is the point she's trying to
make that Hispanics or hard workers and
they don't end up homeless or something
like is she is this Praise of Hispanic
Americans Hispanic I what point is she
trying to make now the the math is sort
of interesting in reality it's estimated
that about 24 of those who were homeless
in 2022 were Hispanic and that's that's
an over-representation relative to the
19 of the population that Hispanics are
believed to make up so 19 of the
population 24 of homeless Hispanics are
over represented in the homeless
population I but I don't know what that
proves one way or the other just as
usual these folks are wrong on the facts
and their analysis and commentaries is
weird now I do want to mention how do
people end up homeless because there is
this idea among many on the right that
when you're homeless it's the result of
a personal failure I actually was at a a
restaurant the other day there was a guy
there with his daughter and also his his
girlfriend it clearly wasn't the the
daughter's mom it was it was his
girlfriend and with his daughter and I
overheard this guy saying if you're
hungry in this country it's by choice
and then five minutes later he yelled at
his daughter and then later at his
girlfriend very loudly in front of a
restaurant full of people it was super
cringy so that that guy is the one who
was saying if you're hungry in this
country it's by choice the truth is that
homelessness in the United States is
often the result of structural factors
poverty lack of affordable housing major
issue not enough housing unemployment
low wages discrimination domestic
violence mental illness substance abuse
abuse lack of social support all of
those things can affect anybody
regardless of race ethnicity gender age
or background but it is true that there
are historically marginalized
communities that are more likely to be
affected by some of those issues one
other thing there's this myth that
homeless people are lazy or dangerous uh
this is also not true as far as lazy uh
the the vast majority of the poor and
many of the homeless actually do work
that's number one and then number two uh
this idea of criminality homeless
criminality the vast majority of
homeless people have never committed any
criminal act other than if a city makes
it a crime to be homeless then you were
criminalizing their very uh status and
we've talked about that happening in a
number of different cities so not sure
what point this woman was trying to make
but at least it gives us an opportunity
to talk about homelessness let's take a
quick break we'll be right back we need
to teach kids to think critically and
independently and we aren't doing a good
enough job of it I have a book right
here that teaches kids critical thinking
I wrote this book and it's available on
Amazon at davidpackman.com book this is
told through the story of a kid
detective the the idea is critical
thinking thinking independently is like
solving a mystery getting clues
evaluating them thinking through
scenarios the right knows that when kids
think critically they don't end up being
Republicans when they're adults and
that's why they hate teaching kids
critical thinking this book alone won't
solve the problem but it will get kids
interested get a copy Kindle paperback
davidpackman.com book